uns hat in den letzten tagen ein sehr
eindrucksvoller corona hilferuf erreicht
von frank knapp dem restaurantbesitzer
aus rüsselsheim ich auch noch mal rein
ich frage euch man geschieht denn etwas
das man langsam jürgen bär von den
herren die uns ständig versprechungen
machen die uns andauernd versprechen
dass eine hilfe kommt etwas geschieht
und vor ein paar tagen habe ich hier
gesessen mit 30 eine leute fest
angestellt seit dieser zeit fragen nicht
meine leute und wie geht es denn weiter
und ich schaue mir gott verdammt noch
mal jede sendung an im fernseh dies zu
dem thema sehen und überall sitzen sie
herr altmaier herr schulze sitzen
überall
und sie versprechen und ständig hilfe
und warum bekommen wir die hilfe nicht
ein sehr emotionaler frank knapp der uns
jetzt auch zu gescheitertes er knapp das
hilfspaket vom bundestag wurde
beschlossen
was ist ihre einschätzung dazu hilft
ihnen das na gut man man muss sagen das
paket vom umland im bund ist beschlossen
wurden ja und ist auf den weg gebracht
aktuell sehe ich da nachdem man sich
über die sache etwas schlauer gemacht
hat und man hat auch sehr viel
information bekommen
das haben wir jetzt über die dehoga oder
im hessischen ministerium sehe ich dass
die soforthilfe alles andere als sofort
kommt also das was mich so wütend
gemacht hat in der vergangenen woche
kommt so langsam wieder hoch nachdem ich
mich etwas beruhigt habe möchte ich
jetzt fast sagen das wird sehr
unangenehm werden für ganz ganz viele
betriebe
sie haben gesagt es dauert alles noch
wann rechnen sie damit hilfe haben sie
in irgendeiner weise information darüber
wann ihnen endlich geholfen wird na gut
wir müssen ja erst mal alle an das
gericht endet nämlich wir müssen erst
mal alle diese anträge stellen nun ist
es aber so dass ihr diese diese dieser
sofort hilfe also dieses paket geschnürt
wurde ja um den betrieben hat sofort
geld zur verfügung zu stellen
das ist ja das ist ja sagen wir mal ein
soforthilfe
viele unternehmen erst einmal die
eigenen die eigenmittel und sämtliche
andere möglichkeiten ausgeschöpft sein
müssen das heißt sie müssen erstmal
alles selbst gemacht haben und alles
probiert haben erst einmal als ein
personengesellschaft oder als als
einfacher kleiner ein mann betrieb oder
als kleines restaurant es keine
kapitalgesellschaft ist das geld zu
bekommen ja das ist auch wenn man die
sachen schaut extrem überbürokratisiert
also ich denke da haben wir auch zwei
jahren von den geben sie uns doch mal
konkret das beispiel in sachen
bürokratie
es ist ein ewig langes formular das
ausgefüllt muss kann das alles online
ausgefüllt werden
was müssen die leute konkret jetzt
ausfüllen wie viele bürokratische
aufwand ist dass der bürokratische
aufwand ist es das ist natürlich immens
ja ich konnte es nur eins sagen es gibt
halt zeit ihm dass die pakete frei sind
oder dass die dinge die eben auch den
weg gebracht werden bekannt sind
überschlagen sich die meldungen man
bekommt hatte mitteilung vom hessischen
der hessischen landesregierung man
bekommt mitteilung von den verbänden
also wir sind ja in der dehoga im
deutschen hotel und gaststättenverband
verband ansässig oder sind wir dabei und
das sind natürlich schon riesige listen
und man muss halt vor allen dingen genau
studieren was bedeutet das dass alle
möglichkeiten der eigenhilfe
ausgeschöpft sind ja man muss ja alles
auch eigene erklärung ich habe noch
nichts gesagt aber würde jetzt die frage
stellen wie gehen in ihrer angestellten
mit der ganzen situation um
na gut wenn wir besprechen das ja jeden
tag also die angestellten sind nach wie
vor in großer sorge und ich sehe ist
einfach so wenn ich mir jetzt als das
betrachtet was ich weiß zu dieser
situation dann kann ich nur sagen
für kleinere betriebe ja wir haben ja
zum glück sind wir etwas größer aber für
die ganz kleinen betriebe ja also wie
ich das wünschen angeschnitten habe ja
für die kleinen gastronomen ja für
gastronomen die quasi als in einer recht
sondern rgb erstehen
die die werden also wenn die nicht sie
müssen erstmal schauen dieses geld von
der bank bekommen die müssen erst einmal
schauen inwieweit sie ihre eigenmittel
verraten haben
und dann bekommen sie den zuschuss das
ist für mich einfach keinen zuschuss und
das muss man einfach mal deutlich sagen
dass man da wohl
wahrscheinlich noch nachbessern muss ja
also so stellt sich die situation dass
bekommen einer angestellten bitten damit
sind man angestellten nach wie vor in
der situation dass wir wissen lang läuft
man ist sofort hilfe ist ein punkt der
ist jetzt gesetzt ja aber diese krise
ist ja eine lineare geschichte das heißt
die zeit schreitet weiter und von uns in
der branche man spricht sich mit
kollegen haben gehen wir nicht davon aus
dass im april oder mai erledigt ist ja
also es wird sehr lange geben und da
werden viele betriebe sterben sehr viele
betriebe sterben lassen sie mich kurz
ein haken wenn wir nicht absehen können
wann die krise vorbei ist will ich
trotzdem gerne von ihnen wissen wie ihr
leben aussieht sollte die krise
irgendwann war dann überwunden sein mir
mein leben aussieht das kann ich ihnen
dann sagen wenn die wenn die krise um es
natürlich ich habe das gestern schon mal
gesagt ich werde alles dafür tun dass
mein betrieb nicht untergeht ich werde
alles versuchen was ich kann alles in
meiner macht steht und ich hoffe dass
ich meinen betrieb an den schengen mein
leben ja weiterführen kann
und das ist auch dass das größte ziel ja
dass das weiter läuft ja nicht nur für
mich auf meine angestellten weil jeder
von meinen leuten die für mich arbeiten
habe ich als unternehmer eine riesige
verantwortung für und die verantwortung
hört einfach damit nicht auf dem ich
sagen jetzt ist schluss sondern dass die
verantwortung geht weiter und wir müssen
gucken jeden arbeitsplatz zu erhalten
aber dafür müssen wir auch einen rahmen
bekommen der uns überleben lässt und da
sehe ich einfach große probleme oder
immer noch große hürden er knapp vielen
dank für das gespräch und ihre
einschätzung zu drücken die daumen dass
sie bald aus dieser schwierigen
situation heraus finden
ich danke ihnen haben einige zuschauer
trotz der frustration halten sich ein
oder der großteil der menschen an diese
coruna regeln zum nachteil natürlich für
die wirtschaft firmen gehen pleite
angestellte müssen entlassen werden und
bei einem
schwindet da ja so ein bisschen die
zuversicht und das können wir mehr
zweifel auf und zwar für den unternehmer
daniel hager chef der firma hager die
sich mit elektroinstallation befasst und
mit zwei milliarden umsatz auch eine
gewisse tragweite hat berger kurzer
einblick von ihnen
wie gestaltet sich ihr leben aktuellen
zeiten der krise ja dass unsere branche
ist ja schon seit januar von der
thematik betroffen und wir versuchen
natürlich jetzt natürlich die ersten
konkreten probleme zu lösen für die
sicherheit unserer mitarbeiter zu sorgen
und dann auch zu versuchen unseren
betrieb aufrechtzuerhalten weil da
draußen sind noch ganz viele unserer
kunden handwerker die arbeiten und die
natürliche unsere produkte brauchen aber
auch dieser handwerker die
systemrelevant sind sind natürlich wie
wir das eben gehört haben von den knapp
in ihrer existenz bedroht wir haben
umfragen dass das handwerk davon ausgeht
50 prozent umsatz zu verlieren und über
50 prozent der unternehmen stehen
stellen schon mal in den raum dass die
kurzarbeit beziehungsweise menschen
entlassen werden müssen und das ist dann
schon eine tragödie die sich da
wirtschaftlich abspielt der haager sie
haben den herrn knapp gerade erwähnt und
auch seine emotionen mitbekommen auch
gerade in der in der video botschaft die
uns zukommen lassen
finden sie die aktuellen maßnahmen zu
hart die maßnahmen sind sicher der
situation gerecht und ich glaube die
bundesregierung hat auch versucht
sicherheit zu vermitteln und alles
mögliche zu tun damit diese humanitäre
und diese medizinische krise nicht
passiert was sich aber im moment
abspielt ist dass wir eine zweite krise
heraufbeschwören und das ist eine
wirtschaftliche krise und wir müssen
natürlich jetzt schauen bzw
die politik muss schauen wie sie mit
dieser rezession die kommt die in
volldampf unterwegs ist wie sie damit
umgehen will
lassen sie mich noch mal anders fragen
ist das ganze dann am ende ja für das
was uns bevorsteht alles wert ich glaube
das kann man nicht miteinander
vergleichen
es geht auf der einen seite natürlich um
menschenleben und jedes menschenleben
ist ist kostbar und muss geschützt
werden und dann müssen wir wirklich
alles tun damit dieses menschen leben
geschützt wird
auf der anderen seite und ich bin
unternehmer und müssen wir natürlich
schauen dass wir unsere betriebe am
laufen halten und dass wir unsere
arbeitsplätze erhalten und dass es keine
dass die wirtschaftliche krise die
natürlich desto länger diese dieser
zeitrahmen dauert desto größer wird sie
dass diese dass wir auch diese krise
aufmerksam machen und um den
grösstmöglichen schaden vermeiden
da ist natürlich noch einiges an
gesprächsbedarf
wir würden dann ihre alternativen dafür
aussehen dass man den größten jahr
möglichen schaden der wirtschaft in
irgendeiner weise noch gering hält
ja ich bin kein mediziner ich bin auch
kein politiker ich denke dass wir auf
jeden fall jetzt erwarten dürfen von der
politik dass sie über eine exit
strategie nachdenken ein unternehmen
braucht planungssicherheit die menschen
in den unternehmen die arbeitnehmer
genauso wie die unternehmer brauchen
planungssicherheit und hier wäre es doch
wichtig wie lange dieser zustand
aufrechterhalten wird unter welchen
bedingungen er aufgehoben werden soll
und wie wir weiter planen sollen ja das
ist glaube ich im moment
das große fragezeichen der hk vielen
lieben dank für ihre einschätzung
bleiben sie gesund